[Music]
hello everyone this is Pete Wilson on us
now they're here to give you another
first look impressions on this game
flaps um from pajama llama games now
they I ended up being introduced to them
back when we were at PAX East in 2019
and I was really sucked into the game
because it was a very different type of
city-builder type game now with normal
city builders it's on land well this is
not on land this is on water and one of
the intriguing things about it is that
the earth is pretty much gone probably
99% of the earth is gone all you see is
random little islands up in random
little spots all over the world now this
game is has very few resources for you
to work with where normally you have you
know your your minerals your waters your
things like that to work with so that
you can end up growing your city in your
town well this is based on the water so
all you get is what all you get is logs
and plastic now these two are kind of
the building blocks to grow up your
whole entire town and the the other
thing is that you have your villagers to
produce your town now how do villagers
survive they survive from food and water
and to get those things you have to
produce many different types of resource
management tools so those resource
management tools are going to be either
the villagers themselves jumping into
the water swimming over to the to the
logs or the wood if you will and then
grabbing those bringing them back to
town or having them jump into the water
and go get your plastic and bring them
back into town now after you start
producing a lot of those early objects
in the game what ends up happening is
you end up then being able to good
produce boats once you produce these
boats they can end up doing
a couple of different things you have
the scavenger boat and you have your
fishing boat the fishing boat you'll be
able to go to fishing pools you'll be
able to get the fish in that and then
you'll be able to bring them back to the
the main base area and then you can dry
the fish and then produce fruit out of
that the and then the other thing is the
scavenger boats which will then able to
take three times the amount of scavenge
out of the water which would be the the
wood or the plastic once you get those
objects you bring them back into the
town you end up then putting bring them
in and then you can work with them that
way the plastic looks to be that it's
mostly for building the main part it's
like the main building block with the
wood but the wood is wet which means you
have to dry it first so once you dry it
you can then end up putting it into a
mechanic's area which would then it be
able to break down the wood and then
make firewood out of it or rope or
whatever you're looking to do with it
now over time you'll you're gonna use
those scavenger boats to go to
observation areas those observation
areas will then end up giving you
multiple different options of things to
do you'll be able to either get more
villagers you'll be able to save animals
you'll be able to get certain resources
or you'll get bonuses and resources like
extra water and then you'll also be able
to get things like oil now the oil will
allow you to go to different maps after
you can either do it from the oil or
with a mast so you can either do one or
the other now just take a step back one
of the things you get is you can also
get this water which is you know
refreshed water so the water itself is
then taken and then it's end up being
cleaned and then able to be drinkable
now you can end up doing that by using a
distiller which will end up burning the
salt water to be able to to drink from
it or you can route you can use research
points which you find on the islands to
be able to then upgrade different types
of things whereas with the water they
have a solar distilling area or the food
area which you can end up then using to
then catch fish randomly on this off the
side of your of the side of your your
your town which is really really neat
now I played this for about three and a
half hours there was very minimal
breakdown in what it was because it is
early access there were a little quirks
here and there which is you know what is
expected but it played very beautifully
the animations were fluid and great the
graphics of it was was fantastic I
wanted to keep playing it over and over
and over again because I thought that
the game ended up having this replay
value of it now the reason why I'm
saying it's got this replay value is
because when you go from zone to zone to
zone you'll end up getting the different
types of quote-unquote events which is
getting the villagers or the people or
I'm sorry the animals or the oil and
things like that
and to do that you need the oil or you
need a mast for your for your boat so
you have those two options but you
consistently can keep going going and
going and once you go to the end it
restarts the whole things you can you
take a different track if you want to
see what else you can get now what I
found interesting is that the it has a
very rimworld ish type mechanic where
you can tell your what your citizens or
your people your villagers should be
able to do specific jobs so what I ended
up doing was I ended up having one
person on the boat essentially making
sure he all he does is cut the wood end
up working on the
the mechanic shed and then I end up
having him do that and then they had
another person specifically working on
distilling the water and then I had
another person that was specifically
moving supplies and also putting things
into the drying racks and taking things
out of the drying racks and then I had
two people
I'm sorry not two people one person
specifically taking all of the the boats
out and being able to fill up the boats
bring him back into the dock once they
brought back into the dock then they
would just hop into another boat go out
so that it almost was like that person
was always working and then the person
that was hauling all the stuff around
he was ending up being constantly
working because he was just going onto
the boats taking the stuff off the boats
and bring them in so you had kind of
this fluid rounding motion of the game
so all my people consistently is went
non-stop now each of the villagers have
different stats on them so they have
fins so some of them can swim faster
than others some of the villagers end up
having you know they require less food
than others some require more water than
others and so each villager has their
own little needs and wants also and each
of your villagers they need the water
they need food they need sleep and they
also have the regular health bar so once
the health bar deteriorates which did
happen for me so one of them
deteriorated and disappeared and when
that ended up happening the
deterioration went away and I actually
ended up losing one of the one of my
villagers and you know yeah a really
interesting like almost like a floating
tombstone where he died and it was kind
of a little gruesome I was just like oh
no I did but you know it happened so we
kind of have to deal with that if you
will I tried this game twice the first
run which is most of the gameplay I have
was flawlessly done
to the to a really good point and I
wanted to see if I could take the
knowledge of the original first run into
the second run to see if I can make it
even better and faster and see if I can
end up making them builds correctly or
build differently or my build orders
because then I learned how to do certain
things more efficiently for instance I
didn't realize that there was a way to
research the items until about halfway
through so once I started learning how
to do that part of the game it ended up
working out pretty nicely so my second
run I was able to get to the crafting of
the the solar water distiller is way
faster and I was able to start working
on getting the the food the kelp fishing
lines and all that weight earlier also
which ended up working out pretty well
so it definitely makes you think and
makes you more efficient now I'm not
sure if they're planning on putting in a
hard mode or a different modes like
rimworld does like Rimmer all day in the
pudding you know they give you five
people right from start and you taste
they figure it out but they also have
like one mode that's like you have
nothing and you have to figure out what
you're doing from scratch so I wonder if
they're gonna ever implement that or be
like okay with one villager see how it
will see how it works so I would really
would love to see what what the pajama
llamas are going to end up doing with
this game to see how to make it more
complicated I do know that when I did
speak to them at PAX East they ended up
telling me that they were gonna be
putting in other things like
environmental environmental problems
because they got really really cool
whales that are floating around but they
said that they were thinking about
putting things in like dolphins and
sharks and things to kind of mess up
your ecosystem so that you can it makes
you think more than just having your
guys just jump in the water and go so
it'll be really interesting to see where
they're gonna end up taking taking the
scheme to the next level and DLCs and
maybe I'll end up having helicopter soon
and you'll be able to do grab things
that way or maybe that you'll end up
getting you know some type of larger
gameplay so I'm very excited to see it
so I would tell everyone if you want a
game you could just kind of veg out and
not think about go pick it up it is on
early access on the 26th of September we
got like I said we got this key front
and directly from from pajama llamas and
I thank them very much for doing this
because I was watching this game
throughout the whole year and I could
not wait to get my hands on it and it
did not disappoint and I'm very happy
that we were able to do this for them so
thank you very much for sitting through
and watching this review my name is now
though
also known as Lord Pete or PD or
whatever you'd like to call me on the
iron Lords podcast team now iron Lords
podcast is on Sundays at eleven o'clock
Eastern Time a.m. football season time
and then one o'clock on football season
and I would greatly appreciate it so
thank you very much everybody and have a
great day everybody
you
you
you
[Music]